now this is interesting because we've
thought about this graph a little bit or
a sine inverse of sine X we drew some
conclusions about this algebraically
right we said that this was equal to do
you remember we wrote down we said it
was equal to whatever angle you provided
X on a certain condition namely we were
restricted it didn't wait how did we
restrict it we restricted it from
negative plan soon to play on soon okay
now a couple of things I know there are
no negative values on there okay so I'm
just considering it from the origin but
as you can see it looks like it checks
out okay
that sure looks like y equals x it is
likely that in this restricted domain
okay there's two dots very close
together because you're one point five
and one point five seven which is pilot
two which is our end point great okay
now what happens later on well you can
see what happens right now it's a bit
difficult because sort of you know
you're my scale your inaccuracies
applauding and people who are greedy and
took other people's points and so on
okay but what kind of behaviors it seems
evening how would you describe it in
words how is his craft behaving it's
familiar isn't it it's supposed to be
linear I know down there it looks like
it's not being linear but I put that
down to do not care C's in the graph
okay here it's a minimal obvious whoever
was um yeah I would make you put your
hands up in embarrass yourself but
whoever's was going from plan to tip I
did a pretty good job whoever went from
PI to
yeah you know who you are say how far
does it go how far does it go now let's
think about this I didn't I said before
I didn't create negative values right so
from negative PI to PI - I'm just on y
equals x nobody's negative PI on - it's
somewhere like here isn't it around here
there abouts woops sorry missed now have
a look at this continuous question that
I have from negative PI to 2 pi on -
okay horizontally speaking how long is
it horizontally it's pi radians right
from here to here so therefore it's a
reasonable expectation to think that
from PI 2 up to here would also be PI
radians so this bottom point here right
well would that be I guess that would be
3 PI to 3 PI - which doesn't look very
plain to me but you know you're getting
the idea okay and then of course it
comes back up for another pi radians
okay line of best fit
oh well ok and then we come down I think
the very last point that someone put on
was 3 PI I mean that's requires ative
nine point whatever nine point four twos
there you go
great now this is interesting to say the
least it looks kind of like sign doesn't
it but it's like sign and someone beat
all of the curvature heaven right okay
now I put a little more negative stuff
over here we know already that this is
what's going to happen now what might
you expect to take place over yeah now
it's a good you know you've got good
intuition if you think it's going to do
the same kind of thing but we can go a
little further than that we can show
algebraically it's going to do the same
thing okay he's allowing that approach
it he got symmetry symmetry um for
functions there's two kinds of symmetry
right what are the two kinds of symmetry
there is even an odd right -
even symmetry is where a function is the
same whether you put in one value or
it's negative that's even symmetry if
that's the algebraic definition of even
symmetry
what's the algebraic definition of WOD
symmetry how's it different all I do is
slap a negative on the front and now
it's on okay now that's an odd function
okay now what you got here is a
composition of two functions right a
function of a function but you know lots
of things especially in terms of
symmetry about both of them
right what kinds of symmetry does each
have sign by by XI when I say even I'm
Peapod and sine inverse of course right
we noticed along the domain that we
restricted it sine inverse had what kind
of symmetry
also on right also closes the
unfortunate one who is an even symmetry
but because of the way we restrict you
restricted cos inverse has no order even
symmetry not at least in this sense
right it does have one symmetry if you
take it about a different point but
that's a point now therefore if I know
both of these are odd what happens when
you take an odd function of an odd
function now you already have some clues
when you look at the graph right you
could probably make a very good educated
guess but can we prove it ok so often
the sign well maybe for me off on the
side but for you underneath here ok
let's consider similar functions ok
consider two and let's call them for the
sake of argument
FNG ok now if I say if I define their
boost to be odd
ok I want to think about f of G or G of
F and does it have any qualities that I
can take advantage of so for instance
both on an even symmetry right have to
do with what happens when you stick in
the negative right F of negative x so if
I went
should have a function I'm gonna do this
F of G you see that so I'm not gonna
stick X in there I'm gonna stick G of X
in well I'm not just gonna stick G of X
I want a even negative x and see what
happens
using what I know about linear functions
so I'm gonna do this is that okay
right now we're justify G as odd
so therefore what can what conclusion
can I drop them this is F of negative G
X right high by G I read negative two
it's on the same sir because G is all
that containers right uh-huh but now
because f is odd it's in this position
right I can say that's negative F alt G
good okay I bring that back to my
original line half of G of negative x
and negative F G what conclusions can I
draw therefore about f of G the odd funk
an odd function of an odd function is an
odd function okay
my brain all right now so therefore what
should you expect assign a message sign
because it's another function of home
function right so now I don't need to
make any guess what I see exactly what's
going on over here
so I can draw the same conclusion okay
where am I going to sit PI at pi all
right negative PI I'm falling like you
guys are right you get the idea it keeps
going right I should actually have some
[ __ ] and it turns around hmm now we're
going to come back to this guy shortly
but I want you to then think about I'm
not going to spend time on it you can
see it appears in the exercises and you
can look at the videos if you like but
obviously this is not the only way we
can combine these and graph them right
you could just as easily do cause the
inverse of cause right well you could do
tan inverse of tan you can swap the
inverse with the original function you
could do 10 of 10 inverse and cause of
cos inverse and sign it sign a mess look
it's really tricky is when you mix and
match would you expect this to look like
we will we will address this question
but I wonder how far you can get on your
own stare what would you guess that it
might look like this is what you see
this looks like okay and how can you
argue that it's the case okay